lil na's x sends love to fka twigs
after getting called out for some
similarities between her music video for
cellophane
[Music]
and his new viral video for montero call
me by your name
on tuesday the 21 year old performer
took to instagram to share that fka
called him and pointed out the
similarities between the two videos
for reference here's a clip from
[Music]
cellophane
and here's montero
[Music]
both videos feature the artists pole
dancing and
free falling through the sky lil na's ex
posted a snippet from cellophane and
wrote in the caption that he wanted to
show love to the singer and
the video's director for the quote
masterpiece
he wrote i was not aware that the visual
would serve as a major
inspiration for those who worked on the
effects of my video
he went on to thank the singer for
calling him adding quote
i understand how hard you worked to
bring this visual to life
you deserve so much more love and praise
you know i'm keeping the
energy positive thomas wang who directed
the music video for cellophane
responded on twitter that it was quote
awesome to see that the choreographer
from
cellophane also worked on montero and
praised little nazex for paying homage
to wang's work
but he also urged major labels to uphold
the director's creative integrity
i feel amazing as for the 33 year old
songstress
she posted on instagram to say thanks to
lil nas for their quote
gentle honest conversations and for
acknowledging the inspiration
cellophane gave him and his creative
team
quote i think what you have done is
amazing and i fully support your
expression
and bravery in pushing culture forward
for the queer community
legend status there's been so much
growth like beyond just
you know the fame and fortune like
mentally spiritually i've grown so much
but this is hardly the first controversy
little nas x has faced over the montero
music video
[Music]
the visual is filled with biblical and
ancient greek references and at one
point
the 21 year old slides down a pole to
hell to seduce the devil
and give satan a lap dance
and while some fans were loving it
others slammed it as
immoral and inappropriate for kids
that's when the musician
fought back on social media pointing out
that his music
is never intended for children tweeting
quote
i am an adult i am not going to spend my
entire career
trying to cater to your children that is
your job
you